etwas glaubt willkommen bei myvideo ich
habe die carlo dabei und zwar haben wir
uns gedacht also ich hab das schon mal
gemacht da hatte ich so kein hahn und
30.000 abonnenten oder so damals mit
meiner jetzigen ex freundin das wissen
vielleicht europas
da ging es halt immer so die niemals zu
deiner freundin sagen solltest und immer
wenn sie halt was als schlimm empfunden
hat dann dürfte sie mir eine klatschen
jetzt wenn es ganz schlimm war so
richtig und wenn es nur ein bisschen
stimme hallt zu halten ja und das ist
immer richtig gut angekommen deswegen
für das muss mal wieder machen und
deswegen ist die arbeit aber wir müssen
vorher sagen ein bisschen nicht zusammen
wir sind nur ganz normal so gefreut aber
das komme trotzdem redet ja und ich will
sagen mir aber gar nicht angefangen
direkt mal an und wir wirtschaft ganz
viel spaß mit euch gefällt immer schön
und danke ja schon dass wir bei dir
drehen dürfen blicken
wieso guckst du eigentlich mal diese
kochsendungen ich wollte versuchen
können
die canucks jochen jaschke was ist immer
sagen wollte
letztlich war das starten und ich hab da
deine beste also ich glaube das war das
war nicht der beste freund ich hab dir
schon mal gesehen habe ich die da noch
mal gesehen und da ist mir das so
richtig klar geworden dies voll hässlich
normalerweise so alle mädchen wenn du
was gegen die beste freundin sachs ist
vorbei bei dir ich nicht diese typische
bauplätzen ja jetzt nicht meine richtige
weg von der richtung
mag sein aber eigentlich eingriff gut du
meinst immer mehr englisch mal weißt du
was ich jetzt gelernt hat was ist
bassist euronext gar nicht also kommt es
gut nicht dass du jetzt machst du so ich
bin aber jetzt ist mal so richtig an der
zeit auch mal ein kompliment zu machen
nicht aber die ganze zeit voll die
doofen situation aber eines muss man ihr
lassen
du bist im bett viel besser als seine
beste freundin geriet bisschen käse aber
ich mag kein käse könnten so musste man
hast dann hast du das letzte mal
gewechselt
plötzlich ok eine sache da muss ja auch
schon wieder weg nur weil und minuten
mit ihr reicht das weißt du ich das
schwimmen also was ich immer schon mal
sagen wollte wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
mit dir gerade manchmal sind die aktive
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das lieber
bringen soll
ich bin jetzt einfach auf den punkt wenn
wir uns küssen oder sex haben dann muss
ich irgendwie immer an meine schwester
ding oder halt deine freunde oder deine
q7 oder halt auch manchmal an alle drei
zusammen aber im mini und ich okay jetzt
wirklich die letzte sache bevor ich rede
so gehst jetzt fitness schule also du
gehst du gehst eigentlich gar nicht ins
fitnessstudio
aber damit man doch das sieht ja dieses
anabole und sohn auf jeden fall dieses
zeug weißt du dann kriegen also damals
vorne und ich habe mich noch nie getraut
ihr das zu sagen aber du hast das voll
und das kratzen affären wenn ich dich
küssen und ähnliches vorliegt
als sonne spaß wollte es mir spaß und
ich will mal sagen das war es erstmal
das waren jetzt auch schon zehn sachen
oder so ne aber stoppt wenn wir jetzt
noch einen zweiten teil wollt oder so
dann lasst auf jeden fall mal daumen
nach oben da den gibt's dann bestimmten
ich sag mal so das schafft ihr locker
15.000 likes auf dieses video dann
gibt's auf jeden fall im zweiten teil
geben jetzt eigentlich auch so gehen
damit ist jetzt viel spaß also ihr könnt
gerne leiden 15.000 ist bestimmt drin
ansonsten ich sagen ihr könnt auch gerne
mal lieber ins ferne vorbeischauen
sie hatten sehr hübsche fotos da
vielleicht dass wir hier kurz ein oder
als auch in der video beschreibung
geschrieben mein install aber ein
gewinde zudem statt auch wenn er mich
gerne folgen abonnieren hier auf youtube
natürlich auch wir sehen uns am nächsten
doch wieder und nicht sogar sonntag
kommt wirklich ein richtig aufwendiges
video glaube ich ziemlich viel arbeit
reingesteckt das ist doch voll von mir
habe ich einfach mal ausprobieren
deswegen checa so hinbekommen 15 uhr ja
lasst euch sagen sie uns